do the right thing that's the focus of
tonight's angle
now if joe biden's presidency or a
disaster movie it would be like titanic
and the poseidon adventure all rolled
into one
not only has the s.o.s biden well ss sos
biden collided with an iceberg it's
capsized
and now democrats are scrambling aboard
what they think is the last lifeboat a
3.5 trillion dollar bmf spending bill
this is in many ways what might define
what his presidency is about will easily
be uh the most dramatic expansion
of the social safety net
since lbj's great society this is going
to be one of
the the key moments
that joe biden is going to have in his
presidency and a legacy defining moment
of course the ropes for that lifeboat
may have already been cut with a 50-50
split in the senate biden can't afford a
single democrat defection or else the
3.5 trillion dollar spenderama goes
nowhere
enter senator joe manchin of west
virginia who came out against this
massive money grab in his wall street
journal op-ed last week saying i've
always said that if i can't explain it i
can't vote for it and i can't explain
why my democratic colleagues are rushing
to spend 3.5 trillion dollars
yesterday axios reported mansion is open
to 1.5 trillion dollars which we also
can't afford and of course that would be
new spending which chuck schumer and
company
resoundedly rejected outright
but that doesn't mean the democrats are
just going to unfurl the white flag oh
no no if biden's ship sinks they all
sync with him schumer and pelosi need
this bloated spending bill as much as he
does
now think of the leverage this gives
mansion
he could theoretically save biden's
presidency
kind of but of course to do that he'd
have to vote yes on a hyper-partisan
bill that by his own admission
could very well exacerbate inflation and
debt that may be a bridge too far even
for a flexible democrat like mansion
which is why the left is using a
two-pronged strategy here one prong
involves plaudits and appeals to party
loyalty
he's always been there he's always been
with me
i think we can work something out joe is
a good democrat he's very persuadable he
is someone
that many times have been willing to get
to a place that's the right place the
other prong is what you see in the press
every day vicious attacks from radical
talking heads
joe manchin is a monster of the
democrats own making because the more
you keep feeding the beast and telling
them that they have control over you
they will exert that control what the
tea party did to hamstring the agenda of
president obama for years west virginia
democratic senator joe manchin is trying
to do to president biden's agenda now a
big problem a problem for biden's agenda
joe manchin practice fighting with joe
manchin practice fighting see how it
feels
i like when joy reid does that's right
that's i love that
well what should be obvious to mention
is that no one you just heard actually
cares if he does what's right for his
constituents in fact
they hate joe manchin's constituents
they help get trump into office after
all and in west virginia a large number
of trump voters also voted for mansion
why because they trusted him when he
said that he wasn't like those other
democrats
as your senator i'll protect our second
amendment rights that's why the nra
endorsed me
i'll take on washington and this
administration to get the federal
government off of our backs and out of
our pockets i'll cut federal spending
and i'll repeal the bad parts of
obamacare
i sued epa and i'll take dead aim at the
cap and trade bill
now where's that guy about don't pick
our pockets
but it's one thing to make a promise on
the election trail and well of course
another one to keep that promise when
the entire democratic establishment is
pressing you to betray your constituents
so we have to ask will mansion hold
well does he surrender to pelosi and
schumer he break faith with the good
people of west virginia and then vote
yes
to help aoc and company move us closer
to socialism or does he do the right
thing and put the interests of his
constituents and all americans ahead of
the hard left
does he side with the squad the rest of
the radicals who hate this country
or will he listen to the people of west
virginia
the latest civics poll has biden's
approval at just 21
in west virginia his disapproval is at
74 percent
so if manchin does the right thing and
just stands up for the people who sent
him to washington
the choice for him is obvious
biden's crazy dream of creating new
entitlements turning america into a
left-wing catastrophe has to be stopped
the people of west virginia didn't vote
for joe biden or pelosi or schumer
they voted for mansion and he promised
that he'd fight for west virginians
so now's the time
kill this nutty bill once and for all
let's start working on rebuilding the
country we love not continuing biden's
disaster movie
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else